ASHISH JHA: Why is
quality important to you,
and how did you begin
working for this area?
MARGARET KRUK: First, I should
say I was a primary care
doc working in a rural,
remote northern Ontario,
and seeing lots of patients
in the hospital and my clinic,
and really losing a lot of sleep over
how to give better care in a really
resource constrained setting.
For Canada, that was a
pretty difficult setting.
And it was a tough job.
And I think we struggled
on how to do that.
And I think we did the best we
could in those circumstances, which
are still so much better than what most
of the world faces, of course, today.
So I've been thinking about quality
as a professional for a long time.
And then I think it came to
global health and public health
and trying to understand
people and patients,
and what are we seeing from the
population surveys, for example.
It struck me, at the very
beginning of my research career,
that people are using some
services but not others.
And so I started asking why?
Why is this?
Why are you skipping facilities?
Why are you bypassing?
Why are you using this
facility for antenatal care,
but you would never
come back for delivery?
What's going on with that?
ASHISH JHA: Yeah.
MARGARET KRUK: And that's actually
when the first signs of the importance
of quality emerged from our research.
And the more work I
did with my colleagues
in Africa, the more people we asked,
the more experiments we performed,
and the more I read, the
more I realized that quality
is fundamental to people
in every part of the world
and for every health condition.
Yes, they define it a bit differently.
People who have a sick
child maybe are immediately
focused on the competence of the
provider, whereas women for delivery
are more focused on
the interpersonal care.
But they all want to get better.
They all want strong skills and respect.
So it's that body of
evidence and work that
really shifted my thinking to
asking the question, what's
actually going on at facilities then?
People demanded, their
actions are based on quality.
What's actually happening
in the health system?
And so for the last
several years, our team
have been looking at just that question.
And that's also led to this work on
the Lancet Global Health Commission
to try to interrogate the point of
intersection between systems and users,
because that's where
health care happens.
And that's where health is built, at
least in terms of the health systems
contribution to population health.
That's where all the work is done.
So understanding what
people expectations are
and understanding what
it is they actually get
has been a huge preoccupation for me.
I think if we don't attend to
that, then the health system is--
I think we forego a massive opportunity
to improve population health,
because the health system
should take its place
as one of the determinants of health.
ASHISH JHA: Yes.